digamos que el año pasado deposite 100
dólares a una cuenta de ahorros en un
banco
esto fue entonces hace un año y hoy
exactamente un año después ese dinero
creció a 110 dólares entonces de tener
100 ahora tengo 110 dólares esto es hoy
si ver las cosas son los términos
absolutos de dólar las cosas crecieron
por 10 dólares así que hice 10 dólares
de una inversión original de 100 dólares
por lo tanto obtuve un 10% de retorno
escribo 10 por ciento de retorno ahora
lo que quiero pensar es lo siguiente
esto realmente cubre lo que podría yo
comprar con 110 dólares que lo que
podría comprar con esos 100 dólares
antes es decir puedo en realidad comprar
10% más de bienes y servicios hoy en día
que hace un año y para pensar en esta
interesante pregunta pensemos en una
tasa de inflación hipotética del año
pasado a este año entonces digamos que
la inflación terminó siendo de 2% si ese
es el caso
cuánto es 100 dólares un año atrás en el
dinero actual bueno si la inflación fue
de 2 por ciento entonces 100 dólares de
hace un año comprarían lo que 102
dólares comprarían hoy entonces sería
102-102 dólares así que nos preguntamos
cuál es el poder adquisitivo real cuál
es el retorno en dólares del dinero de
hoy en día retornen dólar de el dinero
de hoy entonces cada mes estamos
adquiriendo 110 dólares e invertimos en
el dinero actual 102 dólares si lo vemos
en los términos de hoy hemos invertido
algo que nos está dando el mismo poder
adquisitivo de 102 dólares de hoy y
ahora nos está dando un poder
adquisitivo de 110 dólares por lo tanto
estamos obteniendo 8 dólares más de
poder adquisitivo en el dinero actual
así que cuál es el retorno real actual
cuál es el retorno real actual
este el retorno real actual lo podemos
hacer en el dinero actual
puedes hacerlo de cualquier manera
puedes descontar los 110 dólares a lo
que valían hace un año y averiguar el
verdadero retorno ahí a ver y cuando el
verdadero retorno en dólar y hacer los
cálculos o podrías hacerlo en el dinero
de hoy pero el verdadero retorno hicimos
8 dólares en el transcurso del año esto
con dinero de hoy y lo que originalmente
invertimos en el dinero actual fue de
102 dólares así que sacamos la
calculadora 8 dividido por 102 cuánto es
de 7.8 por ciento entonces esto es igual
al 7.8 por ciento así que a pesar de que
el rendimiento nominal si sólo vemos lo
que obtuvimos de intercambio por lo que
invertimos a pesar de que el rendimiento
nominal fue de 10% el que haya habido 2%
de inflación nuestro poder adquisitivo
real solamente aumentó un 7.8 por ciento